Listen attentively cuz you're going to
see what I mean.
>> If IQ is the end all beall, your entire
argument is on the basis of IQ. You
haven't said, you just say, "Oh, uh,
marrying your cousin, effing your
cousin, that is degenerate." On the
basis of what? It's not on the basis of
your Bible.
>> He's right.
You can laugh.
The Bible nowhere says marrying your
cousins is incest. And it's degeneracy.
Where did Andrew get it from? He's
right.
This is where Christians are going to
get embarrassed.
Christians, do you know there's not a
single verse in the Bible that condemns
getting married to your cousins? He's
absolutely right.
Do you know when God forbids sexual
relations, he never includes first
cousins or second cousins?
So laugh like he did. He just buried
Andrew. He did, guys. I'm not lying. He
won.
This is why
Andrew and others should stay in their
lane.
Don't argue on the basis of moral
superiority
against a Muslim when you're appealing
not to divine revelation anchored in
scripture and tradition, but in secular
humanistic ideology and ethical systems.
I'm going to show you.
No, there is not a single verse.
No, there's not. Let me repeat. Do you
want me to repeat it again? There's not
a single verse that says you cannot
marry your first cousin. You think I'm
lying? Okay,
we can stop there. All right, here you
go. Even in Catholic tradition, Orthodox
tradition, they don't have a Bible verse
they appeal to. They don't appeal to
biblical revelation.
Go right here. See, you're not Bible
verse. Go right here.
I give you new advent.org. On what basis
did the Catholic Church condemn marriage
to first cousins, second cousins? It
wasn't on scripture. But then later it
had to then lax that condemnation
prohibition.
It's right here.
Can cons.
That's why even Andrew had to appeal to
what he called canon law.
Consenuinity.
Ah, that word. It's right here. But
here, I'm going to show you what an
evangelical website says, and we're
going to go through the lists.
So, Andrew lost the debate because he
didn't argue on divine revelation.
How you going to win this debate?
Because you were influenced by culture.
Yep. Exactly. You got it. Watch here.
I'm not lying. Here. Got questions is an
evangelical website.
Look. And we're going to go through the
list of forbidden relations.
Let's go here.
Is it wrong to have a romantic
relationship with a close relative?
The relationships that God forbade,
we're going to get to Leviticus 18. It
doesn't say that, brother. The
relationships that God forbade in the
Old Testament law are listed in
Leviticus 18 6 to18. In that passage,
Israelites are commanded not to commit
incest, which is a viling sin. The law
lists relationships, whether involving
marriage or not, that God defined as
incestuous. An Israelite man was not to
marry or have sex with the following
people. His mother, his steparent, his
sister or halfsister, possibly
stepsister of no biological relation
brought up as the daughter of his
biological parent, his aunt, his
daughter-in-law, his sister-in-law as
long as his wife was living.
Interestingly,
marriage between cousins is nowhere
forbidden in the Bible. Why did you
misquote Leviticus 18:6?
Now let's go through the list.
Let's go through the list. Your hate of
Islam
is greater than your love for truth when
you use these kind of arguments. He was
right. Daniel was right
because they have no explicit teaching
not to marry cousins. So now they're
going to make it up as they go along.
The Bible could have said, "Do not marry
your uncle's daughter. Do not marry your
aunt's daughter." Whether there's a word
for cousin or not,
you could have conveyed it by saying,
you could have said it, do not marry the
daughter of your uncle, the daughter of
your aunt.
Except the facts,
there is nothing in the Bible that says
marrying your first cousin is incest.
Now, does that mean you should marry
your cousin? No, I didn't say you should
marry your cousin. What I'm saying, this
argument that he used is not a biblical
one. So, he's got to stop pretending
that he's arguing from the Bible. He's
not. He's arguing from
science. He's arguing from our knowledge
of science that this leads to genetic
deformities,
but it's not a biblical argument.
Well, pray for me, brother. The Holy
Spirit reign me in and own me and fill
me because I'm You don't know how bad my
flesh is kicking in.
Now, let's go through the list. Let me
repeat to you guys saying there's no
word for cousin. Is there a word for the
daughter of your uncle, the daughter of
your aunt? How do we know that Lot is
Abraham's nephew? Because it says the
son of his brother.
So, let's see what lists are forbidden.
Do you have that? And if your solos
scriptor tota scripter sucks being you,
let's read now the forbidden list, shall
we? NIV and then we're going to get
ready for it. I'll come back. You guys
want me to come back and do the sins of
the friends of God and the prophets of
the Bible doesn't sugar coat.
Show me where it says do not marry the
daughter of your uncle or the daughter
of your aunt.
Daniel was right. So what was Andrew
Wilson on? Andrew, brother, he even said
that if it was theology, Daniel would
destroy him. Then why did you make it
theological?
Why didn't you make it practical,
biological, stay away from theology?
Because Daniel kept saying, "Christians
and Muslims have the same understanding
and values in respect to this." And he
was telling Andrew, you're you're basing
your argument on secular, humanistic,
atheistic
worldview. And he was right.
But brother, did you hear what I just
said? The Bible doesn't condemn it, and
it's prevalent in many Christian
cultures. The Lord said to Moses, "Speak
to the Israelites and say to them, I am
the Lord your God. You must not do as
they do in Egypt where you used to live,
and you must not do as they do in the
land of Canaan where I'm bringing you.
Do not follow their practices. You must
obey my laws and be careful to follow my
decrees. I am the Lord your God. Keep my
decrees and laws for the person who
obeys them will live by them. I am the
Lord. No one is to approach any close
relative to have sex relations. I am the
Lord. Now what's close relatives? Do not
dishonor your father by having sex
relations with your mother. She's your
mother. Do not have relations with her.
Do not have sexual relations with your
father's wife. Remember that was a sin
at Corenth 1 Corinthians 5 where a man
took his father's wife's stepmother and
Paul condemned it. Remember 1
Corinthians 5
that would dishonor your father.
Okay, watch.
I don't know. I wouldn't have used that
argument because I know the problems
with that teaching.
Do not have sexual relations with your
sister either with your father's
daughter or your mother's daughter. You
see how clear it is? even if she's not
your full sister, a halfsister, whether
she was born in the same or elsewhere.
Do not have sexual relation with your
son's daughter, meaning your
granddaughter or your daughter's
daughter. That would dishonor you. Do
not have sexual relations with the
daughter of your father's wife, meaning
your stepsister.
Notice stepsister
born to your father. She's your sister
or your halfsister in this case, but
even a step, right? Do not have sexual
relations with your father's sister.
your aunt. She's your father's close
relative. Do not have sexual relation
with your mother's sister because she's
your mother's close relative. Do not
dishonor your father's brother by
approaching his wife. Notice what it
didn't say. Do not dishonor your
father's brother by approaching his
daughter, your cousin to have sex with
she is your aunt. You see guys, it could
have said, do not dishonor your father's
brother by re by approaching his
daughter.
Do not right dishonor your mother's
brother or your mother's sister or your
father's sister by approaching their
daughters.
Do not have sexual relations with your
daughter-in-law. She is your son's wife.
Do not have relations with her. Do not
have sex relation with your brother's
wife, your sister-in-law. That would
dishonor your brother. Do not have
sexual relations with both a woman and
her daughter. Two for the price of one.
Do not have sexual relation either with
her son's daughter, a woman's
granddaughter,
or her daughter's daughter. They are
here close relatives is wickedness. Do
not take your wife's sister as a rival
wife and have sexual relations with her
while your wife is living. If she dies,
you can marry a sister. Do not approach
a woman to have sexual relations during
the uncleanness of her monthly period.
Do not have sex relations with your
neighbor's wife and defile yourself with
her.
Do not give any of your children to be
sacrificed to Malik, for you must not
profame the name of your God. I am the
Lord. Do not have sexual relations with
a man as one does with a woman. That is
detestable. Do not have sexual relations
with an animal and defile yourself with
it. A woman must not present herself to
an animal. To have sexual relations with
it, that is a perversion. Pray tell.
Where do you find the Bible saying don't
get married to your cousins?
All right. Damn, Gina,
show it to me.
So,
let's see now when we go to Chef Google,
the greatest scholar ever lived. Chef
Google. Let's see what it says.
Okay. And then we're going to look Iser
right here. Sheh Google the greatest
scholar ever lived and I gave you an
article from New Advent on the Catholic
position. Okay. Now you just put in put
in
Catholic Church are marrying first
cousins. The Catholic Church considers
marriage between first cousins to be
forbidden by ecclesiastical law but not
divine law
which means a bishop can grant a
dispensation to permit it. That was
Daniel's point. It's not anchored in
divine revelation.
We're going to look at the Eastern
Orthodox.
This dispensation is possible because
the impediment is not a matter of divine
law. Right? See, it's not a matter of
divine law. That was his point
and is granted for sufficient reason. A
couple seeking this must meet with their
local priest to gr permission from their
dio dio uh these words cassin bishop.
Then the marriage must also be legal
under civil law. That's it. That was his
point. Daniel Kikuchu says, "Not your
Bible." Was he wrong?
He didn't. He just repeated the same
thing.
What did Daniel say? Not your Bible. He
was right. He knew more of the Bible
than Andrew did. We're going to go back
and play that clip. Then we're going to
go to our friend
William who puts people to sleep
especially with the singing.
What about Eastern Orthodox Church?
Eastern Orthodox Church prohibits
marriage between first cousins
classifying it as prohibiting degree of
kinship under its canon law. That's why
I appealed to canon law. While the
provision is generally considered fixed,
a bishop may grant an exception in
certain circumstances.
There you go.
He could only appeal to can of law. But
what did Daniel say? Not in your Bible.
He won the debate on that point alone.
Here,
let's go.
So, why do we argue this way?
What happened? What? They removed the
video. Get out of here. Did they remove
the video